foreign
comes from Britain in Georgia Britain
writes I'm 29 years old and I'm
currently on baby step two I net around
27 000 a year and I owe 4 500 bucks in
student loan debt and 78 000 on a
mortgage on a condo that I co-signed for
with my stepmom two years ago to build
my credit score
this was before I learned the
quote-unquote Ramsay way I thought going
into debt was a normal part of life I
talked to my dad and stepmom about
refinancing to get my name off the condo
and they said no because the monthly
payment and interest on the loan is so
low and they're renting out the condo to
pay their mortgage on their house if
they refinance they'll have to pay a few
hundred more a month oh
way so they're going to continue to bury
their 29 year old son so they save a
couple hundred bucks a month what a
great mom and dad wonderful way to go
dad and stepmom my question is that was
John commentary by the way my question
is I realize now that co-signing on a
mortgage wasn't a smart move ta-da on my
part and I'm wondering how this will
affect my ability to get my own mortgage
going forward if they won't refinance
and if they won't refinance what should
my next step be
what a pickle we found ourselves in
Brenton what a pickle well I'm glad
we've we've learned the lesson here and
this is going to be a hard conversation
with Mom and Dad saying hey my future's
on the line here and I regret this
decision and I want out and this is part
of the risk of co-signing because guess
what you could stop paying yeah and
guess who that mortgage would fall on
your parents so you say we can do this
the hard way or we can do this the easy
way
the easy way is you allow me to
refinance and you figure out how to
cover a few hundred extra bucks a month
on the small mortgage so that I can live
my adult life because I am broke I net
27 Grand a year I'm in student loan debt
I need to get out
and uh I hope that works right I mean
there's I don't know that you can force
it you can talk to
um you know Churchill Mortgage they'll
explain the deal when it comes to debt
to income ratio and the timelines and
when you would be able to buy a house if
this is still sitting uh on you but I
would do my best to get out of this and
I do I I George I don't know
oh here's what I want you to check on
Brenton I think if you called an
attorney
you were you were basically dissolving a
partnership here if you co-sign on a
loan and if you say I want out of this
partnership and my partner refuses to
let me out I think I may be wrong
because this may just be a business
transaction but I think you can take
them to court and the judge will force a
sale
and they force a sale and then you split
the proceeds and partners in a pear tree
because my guess is that this place also
has Equity into it that you've bought
into over the last two years and the
house is probably the the house has
probably gone way up the condo is
probably escalated in value
significantly in Georgia and so you've
got money built into this thing even
just walking away from it as a gift to
your dad and stepmom who just love you
so much that they want to keep you tied
to this thing but you can force it I
think George brings up a good point we
can do this the hard way or the easy way
the easy way is I need y'all to sign
this over the hard way is I refuse to be
held back in my life by a decision I
made when I was 25 years old I screwed
up I'm sorry but I want to move on with
this and
at the end of the day here's what's
gonna be hard your parents may choose
that couple hundred dollars a month over
a relationship with their son they might
make that choice
and that says more about them than it
does you so if you have to say okay cool
I learned my lesson I will never co-son
on anything ever ever again and by the
way
I'm sorry that y'all walked away from
your son over a couple hundred bucks a
month good grief and by the way Britain
twenty seven thousand dollars a year at
age 29.
you're gonna have to make some more
money man you're gonna have to make some
money that's not a judgment statement
that is me saying I love you enough to
that I see your value in you that you
don't see and I want you to put yourself
in a better financial position at 29 so
that when you're ready to buy a house
you got the money to do so yeah that's a
good call you don't have to lean on
schemes and hey man will you help me out
to build a credit score right yeah the
good news is you being a homeowner is
not anytime in the near future with this
level of debt and income and so it's
going to be a while anyways uh now you
can still get the info I would still do
your homework talk to an estate attorney
you can talk to Churchill Mortgage and
they can give you the rundown on what
that looks like with debt to income
ratio but right now what you wouldn't
qualify for a mortgage as it stands so I
I wish you the best in getting out of
the situation man it's just one of the
many reasons we tell you never to
co-sign debt and never have a mortgage
with someone you're not married to yes
it's just messy and it hurts
relationships every time